- I love this pink.
- Oh, thank you very much.
- [Kelly] You go with our whole vibe.
- Thank You. Thank You.
Well, you know, I'm sitting
next to a bonafide star.
If I may.
And you guys I've known, I
feel like my, your whole lives.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I was
like, not you changing.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Well, wait, we were
talking about the moon.
- Sit up straight by the way.
- Okay. Thank you.
- I'm sorry
- She's a mom.
So wait, we were talking
about the moon earlier cuz of their movie.
So your father, what did he do?
Cause you had moon rocks.
Like real rocks from the moon.
- My father was a geophysicist for NASA.
- Wow.
- He was a geo chemist. Yeah.
- My grandfather was a geologist.
- Was he really?
- Not for NASA?
- [Kelly] (laughing) Not for NASA.
- Why was rocks a thing that
they were interested in.
- The still are.
They're still around everywhere.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] No I know,
but specifically rocks on the moon,
that's cool.
- Yeah. So
- Your show and tell must have been off
- That, he actually
don't tell anybody Kelly.
The government's listening.
(audience laughing)
- Oh you weren't supposed to, oh.
- Yeah. Yeah.
He brought some home and I
got to bring them for show
and tell and it was not allowed people.
Um but I
- [Kelly] I would've done it.
- Yeah. It was very cool.
This was in the sixties.
Like now you guys are
like, doesn't like Bezos go
to space every other week
and bring back rocks.
- [Kelly] Or maybe just orbit.
We haven't figured it out.
Anyway, okay.
So I wanna get to Abbot Elementary.
So you're in Abbot Elementary
for anyone who doesn't know that
or hasn't seen the first season.
Can you tell everybody what it's about?
- Sure.
- Your family seems a little shady.
Just saying your background.
- Are you talking about
my personal family?
- [Kelly] (laughing) No!
- I'm also Sicilian.
- No no no, you're family in the,
in the show.
- Okay. So no, but you're not wrong.
Um, so the show is a mock-umentary
like The Office or Modern Family
but it takes place in an
underfunded Philadelphia school
or Philadelphia as they say back there.
So my, you know, it's like this
I talk lot like this and
she's a south Philly girl.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Who's from a Sicilian family
and there's always a connection.
Like you need something,
I got a guy for you.
Which happens to be true in real life.
- [Kelly] Your family is like that.
- Oh yeah. I got, I had uncles.
I had an uncle Tony that
was like, what do you need?
You like coloring?
And then you'd go
in a back closet and there'd just be
floor to ceiling swag.
Just, anything you want.
Your mother like wine.
And I, I made this in the backyard, like.
- I think we call that a hoarder.
That has like everything.
- Maybe in Texas it's a hoarder
In, in, in the New York tri-state area.
That's mobbed up. That's what
- [Kelly] It's just prepared.
- That's, that's stuff
that fell off the truck.
- [Kelly] Oh my God. (laughing)
Okay. So wait.
So we all had teachers.
- I'm not allowed to say that.
- [Kelly] You can.
- That was, that was a
legend because you know
there's a thing called omerta, so
- Oh My God.
- But yes it is, it is my family
cuz my mom was a Sicilian
who taught school in a,
in a downtown DC.
- [Kelly] So that's kind of cool
for your character to kind of lean into.
- Oh, a hundred percent.
I get to pay homage to my
mom who I, I lost right
before the show started filming.
- [Kelly] Oh man.
- Last, last June, so.
- I'm so sorry.
- Thank you.
Don't let me cry.
We're on a happy show, lets go.
- No, we're in a happy show.
It's so colorful.
- Yes.
- No, but we all did have a teacher
I feel like that was monumental
like growing up, like,
and really helped us
or changed us or did something for us.
What I wanna know, did
any of you have that?
- Well, I was homeschooled
from pretty much.
- So this is your chance
to say your mother
- Um actually, uh I wouldn't
have trusted my parents
with schooling me in the slightest.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Wait, you were
homeschooled, but not by your
- I was working on, on
a show when I was a kid.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's right.
- The set teachers are amazing.
- Shirley Lauratorn, she's like,
she's like my grandmother.
She she's the greatest.
I would walk in and she
would be very zany woman.
She would be chewing her toenails just
- Oh my
- That's limber.
- And she, but truly
- Yeah I'm really impressed at how limber
- I needed one on one
education, you know what I mean?
I, I needed, I needed the attention.
- But then you went to
like a hoity toity school.
- I did.
- So these people, I mean
they get a great education
while the kids work on set.
- Oh, it's way better that way.
- I love that you just totally are like
my parents couldn't have done this.
- No, no absolutely not.
- All of us that are moms are, are totally
into teaching these kids
and we've got kids that are
I mean, they're they recognize
me from the parent trap.
So they think I'm that character.
And that blows my boss Quinton
Brunson who created the show
and stars in it and is
all of 32 years old.
And this tall, she's like amazing.
- That's amazing.
- She's amazing right?
And she's like, that is
an entire baby that just
recognized you from a
movie that's 28 years old.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But, but honestly
- It's great movie.
- It is a good movie, but
it's hard for me not to parent
not just the kids, but
the grownups on the show.
I mean, you saw me like sit up.
- I mean' you just told
me to sit up straight.
- Yeah. And you're a ballerina, so.
- She's a ballerina people.
I read about you.
- That's always my stylist,
my stylists will, will
Were you a ballerina?
- You didn't know this?
- You know what that's long in the past.
I am not physically capable
whatsoever these days.
- Wait, wait, wait.
- Do a pat e deux.
- I will not.
- One just one.
- She said not one.
- Look I'll do it.
- Watch, watch.
- I love it.
- Wait, wait, you read about her.
You were just gonna skim a over.
- Listen, listen, listen, listen.
I missed, I missed my connecting flight
the other day in Utah.
And I only had to run
through one terminal.
And by the time I got to the
end, I thought I was gonna die.
I was like, I will never run again.
- That's also called almost 40.
- Yeah. That's awesome.
- I pulled my back out this morning,
and I can't breathe
fully without spasming,
which is why I'm sitting here, like.
- Yeah.
- I'll tell you something,
wait until you get to
my age, you do a sneeze
- [Kelly] Age is beautiful.
- And you like, first
of all, wet your pants.
- That's also having children.
- Yes. Thank you. Thank you girl.
- Oh my God, there's no segway.